a cesarean section often referred to as
a c-section is a surgical procedure in
which incisions are made in a woman's
abdomen and uterus to deliver a baby
some cesarean sections are planned more
often however the need for the procedure
becomes apparent after the onset of
labor when abnormal conditions make a
vaginal delivery unsafe for the mother
or her baby common indications for
cesarean section include dystocia
placenta previa and fetal distress
dystocia or prolonged non progressive
labor can occur when the baby's head is
unable to fit through the birth canal or
its body is in an unfavorable position
such as perpendicular to the birth canal
or buttocks first which is the breech
position placenta previa occurs when a
low-lying placenta partially or
completely blocks the cervical opening
fetal distress occurs whenever the
health of the baby is in imminent danger
usually from inadequate blood flow
through the placenta or umbilical cord
fetal distress can occur when the
placenta separates from the wall of the
uterus prior to delivery or the
umbilical cord becomes compressed or
squeezed other conditions that may
require a caesarean section include
multiple births large tumors of the
uterus
genital herpes or other infections or
medical problems such as uncontrolled
diabetes or hypertension your doctor may
use ultrasound testing and a fetal heart
monitor to help decide whether your
babies should be delivered by caesarian
when a caesarean section becomes
necessary you will be prepped for
surgery if not already in place an
intravenous line will be started and a
catheter will be inserted into your
bladder to drain urine in the operating
room you will be given anesthesia in
most cases a spinal anesthetic is
administered to numb the lower portion
of your body sometimes however a general
anesthetic will be used your doctor will
begin by making an incision in your
abdomen it will either be a vertical
incision
from just below the navel to the top of
the pubic bone or more frequently a
horizontal incision across and just
above the pubic bone this is often
called a bikini cut your doctor will
then make a second incision on the lower
part of the uterus
once the uterus is opened your doctor
will rupture the amniotic sac if it is
still intact and deliver the baby the
time from the initial abdominal incision
to birth is typically 5 minutes
your doctor will then clamp and cut the
umbilical cord
gently remove the placenta and tightly
suture your uterus and abdomen this
typically takes about 45 minutes the
hospital stay after a cesarean section
is usually three to five days during
this time you will be encouraged to
breastfeed nap when the baby sleeps and
get out of bed often while most patients
are able to take care of their new
babies soon after the procedure full
recovery may take six to eight weeks
your scar will lighten as it heals